Robert when I looked through your book
rejected I was fascinating to me to see
all these great names and tech art music
that were turned down and some pretty
harsh ways yeah you know like I think
the Marilyn Monroe one I someone said
like find a husband or dig up
secretarial skills yeah and I'm
wondering how much of writing a book was
actually your own form of either like
cell therapy or like a letter to
yourself it wasn't done so deliberately
but it definitely became that I am it
was just comforting for me to see that
look everything I've written has made
ahead isn't great and sometimes you know
it's it's right not to get purchased or
whatever but sometimes I feel like you
know they're wrong like the the
gatekeepers or whoever it is that you
know what this is worthy this this
shouldn't just died and it was very
comforting for me to see to learn that
so many people had experienced major
rejection and really one of the keys is
I'm sure there are tons of people that
will never hear of in all endeavors all
fields who were rejected five times ten
times one time and were brilliant at
whatever it is they did and they gave up
and we'll never hear about so
perseverance and all that kind of stuff
it was very sort of them inspiring for
me to see that that these great artists
had just gone through it and they had to
land maybe they're right or I can't take
this anymore that kind of stuff so it
was definitely comforting to me yeah
have you always had thick skin or maybe
you're not thick skin but does that play
into part I kind of don't have thick
skin really I kind never have had thick
skin I am I am and sometimes I think for
me it's it's definitely a disadvantage
in terms of my stress level kind of
stuff like I take stuff very personally
and I I get but you know it's sort of
what you do about it
something can be a stumbling block or it
can be a stepping stone that kind of
thing so yeah I'm I always have pretty
thin skin but you know after all I guess
it becomes thick because you just sort
of soldier through it but every
rejections hurts and yeah you don't give
off that appearance that you have thin
skin you seem like you're confident and
the things don't get to you so what's
your advice to other people that they
have that living inside of them because
I've seen a lot of great people give up
and become really disillusioned and
leave la become upset because they got
this one person telling them something
terrible about their work and it was
just that one person and they just had
it right I mean you know I hesitate to
say this because it's kind of harsh but
frankly I think if you're the kind of
person who gives up when you get some
particularly harsh criticism or you
don't really belong wherever it is so I
think you know for me I am I tend to I
have a big ego you know and I very often
will say I have trusted friends and
people that I will show stuff to
whatever it is a script or whatever and
I'm totally open to feedback and usually
I'll agree with it sometimes I won't so
when i'm about to send it out to the
world and to gatekeepers and producers
tough stuff like that i'm generally in a
place with that material where I feel
like it's bulletproof so really
nothing's going to get me off my game
where I think yeah maybe they're right
maybe I should just I'm not supposed to
be doing this and before before I sort
of kit you know I say that mindful of
the fact that I've actually had some
stuff produced so what about the person
that never has and they're like maybe
the person's right maybe these people
are right I shouldn't be doing this to
that I would say if you have this
passion inside you like I need to write
a book or write a script or make a movie
whatever
do yourself on a very small scale you
know and and then you'd have to worry
about sort of the tastemakers and things
like that yeah did Wall Street
strengthen your your thin skin you think
being on Wall Street maybe I mean
because a lot of Wall Street's dealing
with strangers and people are rude and
hang up on you and and that kind of
stuff in business it's cutthroat for
sure down there but I think just as a
function of getting older you know after
being alive for a certain amount of time
you deal with all this kind of stuff and
it either strengthens you or it squashes
you and you know you're that kind of
person or you're not I just believe that
if somebody has this thing that they
need to do they're going to do it and
there's it doesn't matter if there are
10,000 people saying no it's either
going to spur them on to continue and
you just put their nose down you know
head down and or they're gonna just
crumble and they're going to say okay
and that's not the kind of people we
need making stuff like so let them go
back to wherever and be a plumber that's
that's that's life you know tough right
can you get squashed and then reset I
think you have to kind of get squashed
it's just a question of how you deal
with it I don't know event there
probably are examples of famous
whatevers who just got lucky and right
out of the gate they come this way you
know like you're a star but it's very
unusual i think it's i think it's an
important part you know we talked a
little bit about this before but going
through there's an old saying i almost
don't want to say it because i'm using
it in a script but it's such a dish that
you it's I'll say it now I'm going to
say it all right so um so yeah so yeah I
think you need to sort of get tossed
around a little bit to strengthen your
resolve and to you know see what you're
made of kind of thing and I think it's
helped your art helps all that kind of
stuff if you have it easy you know if
you just like boom I think your art
suffers for it I think it's important to
sort of go through some tribute
you